what's going on reject nation we got
ourselves
a dark side trailer specifically titled
omega beams which i'm very much excited
about because
if you guys don't know i mean imagine
99.9 percent of you do you know but in
case it
just don't happen enough it's not like
superman's optic blast those omega beams
they can like lock on like a like a
missile to a certain extent like they
track a target
they zigzag around if they get to their
target superman could have a hard time
getting a speedster whereas
someone like darkseid could have a much
easier time catching a flash
oh boy so that's not gonna come in handy
during this movie and kryptonians as
well
so like the omega beam blasts or or
something really i could say i if
we see it i'm hoping to see it i'm
excited it says omega beam so you got to
see it at one point right
i would imagine i don't hope so geez
but yeah it's like watching the game
snake but
cooler electron cycles almost
there's an attack coming
it's not coming it's all ready
oh we got it
fly
let's play it back oh let's play it back
we're gonna play the whole thing back
and then we'll play it back
that slow motion part
[Music]
love that there's an attack on
where is it where is it was that said
atlantis
it's got to be yeah okay
[Music]
we're in the speed force all right let's
really play this [ __ ] back
that up could you not be excited for
this
gosh this looks larger than that i mean
if you were someone who wasn't even for
the snyder cut
you should be for it now i have to say
it man i haven't hopped aboard
this point this is so good yeah it looks
like atlantis look at all these
dead people so many dead atlanteans and
uh
it looks like dark side just doing it
all through omega beam blast look at oh
it's so cool
the geometry oh you know what's so funny
is i've always known that about it as a
mega bean blast
and and yet for some reason didn't even
think if we're gonna see it in this
movie i didn't even
question whether or not it would be in
here i i just kind of forgot like oh
yeah we might
we might actually see him use them for
so long it's felt like this would just
never be a thing so i feel like just
it's becoming a thing makes you excited
for literally
anything you're given to the point where
yeah maybe you forgot about little
wishes like this
you know that rip something again that
takes zack snyder's ability to rip
things
right off of comic book pages in a way
you've never seen before you know
you know what i'm loving about this this
marketing so much again steppenwolf and
darkseid because this easily could have
still still felt like even with zack
snyder uh at the helm again this easily
still could have felt like kind of
whatever stepping wolf get out of the
way like darkseid's the one who's really
scared yeah
because that's usually how it goes when
you got ultimate batty and
main support main support in it for the
baddie right main hench
yeah the main guy is usually not a
general guy that scary or that
intimidating you're kind of just like
uh whatever lag i know we're gonna have
to get to the final boss let's just do
it
but what's cool is like they both look
super scary they both
seem so intimidating and yeah especially
when you get a chance to watch it in hd
version my god this looks good oh yeah
well i'm just looking at it and with you
know obviously you know more about the
stuff than i do but even with what i
know about like the history of
their connection to each other like
their family bond and things like that
like it really looks like we're gonna
dive
into that the way you might in like a
lord of the rings where you really see
like who your enemies are and that you
know steppenwolf
is his own formidable force as well as
dark souls so yeah steppenwolf is
darkseid's uncle
yeah steppenwolf i i believe his mother
hegra is
is in uh the box the box that mainly
goes to creating
uh cyborg steppenwolf probably doesn't
really like starkside
even though he has to be a servant to
him so father's going to be a really
complex layer here
he's going to join the team at the end
yeah jordan
something darker won't join the justice
league
all right guys well this is awesome um i
really can't wait for this man that was
beautiful beautiful omega babes
all right guys well subscribe hit that
like button click that notification bell
it's a great movie this is a fantastic
oh wait no we're we've only seen that
yeah we haven't gotten to see it yet
i assume it's great i assume it's the
best thing in the world i assume
and you know talking with zach is also a
great experience i love talking with
zack snyder
i've done it a lot oh wait on my channel
beyond the trace
wait a minute that's right
[Music]